[Music]
everyone before we get started
I know this might be a hard episode to
watch but like all the other hard
episodes on my channel I felt like these
stories needed to be heard I want to
thank everyone who submitted a video
even if you don't see it in this episode
I want you all to know that I was moved
by your stories you guys made me cry you
made me laugh and most importantly you
gave me hope also I wanted to announce
that a few months ago I partnered with
PBS and we had this really big project
in mind but with everything that's
happening it just didn't feel right so
instead we put together this episode as
you all know up until this point I
haven't done any partnerships and that's
not because I'm opposed to them but
because I always said that if I ever do
it would have to be with someone who
fits into the community we've built here
PBS is working on a series of
documentaries called American portrait
and please trust me when I tell you that
this project definitely fits into what
we're all about
and how we love to share and hear real
stories the American portrait project is
basically a national storytelling
project that explores what it means to
be American today and what's cool about
it is that the documentary series will
be compiled of videos photos and written
work that you'll submit on their web
site pbs.org/newshour on is the
coronavirus so similar to the episode
we're doing right now at the top of
their website will be the topic where
you'll be finishing off the sentence I
never expected dot dot dot please check
it out and submit a story when you get
the chance the more people that
contribute the better the documentary
will turn out I'm gonna submit one to
you and you never know maybe we'll all
end up in the documentary together with
that said let's get started on today's
episode here are answers from all around
the world of people finishing off the
sentence
I never expected this is gonna be so
weird
I never expected I never expected I
never expected I never expected I never
expected that I would be able to see my
grandparents whenever I wanted I never
expected to have my freedom taken away
[Music]
well I never expected that even amidst
the quarantine I would be drafted into
the military right and I wouldn't be
able to see my family for an unknown
period of time I never expected that I
would be part of a future history lesson
I never expected that Friday March 13th
would be my last day of high school and
I still don't know if it was or not I
never expected to be unsure if I would
graduate I never expected to miss going
to school I never expected that I would
have such a hard time not talking to
people like right behind me
my mom made 20/20 vision boards for me
and our family and we weren't expecting
this so now I thought that humans would
be caged and animals would be able to
roam freely in this world I never
expected that my dad would get the
carnal virus my dad is currently it's
March 21st he's currently in the ICU
with pneumonia at the corner hires an
intubation which means he asked that too
giving oxygen to his heart and lungs I'm
holding a lot of Hope holding him in
love and we call that sunlight and just
this belief that he will get through
this I never expected to be working on
the front line of a pandemic my second
year as a registered nurse it all
started a few weeks ago when I was put
in charge of testing page
for the coronavirus at work and since
then that's pretty much all we've been
talking about I never expected to be
considered an essential service I hadn't
realized how much my job means in terms
of like what's needed in society it's
weird to be in a business that's
definitely profiting off of what's going
on we've had to stop people from buying
like 16 of something because other
people need it too you know it's a very
weird time to say the least yeah I never
expected to fit in I'm legally blind I
have a degenerative eye disease called
retinitis pigmentosa and before all this
coronavirus stuff social distancing has
kind of been my day-to-day reality it's
really difficult for me to gain access
to traditional social spaces and work
environments because of the amount of
stigma that still exists around
disability but with all the coronavirus
stuff happening for once I feel like I'm
doing the same thing as everyone else
and I'm on the same page as everyone
else
I'm kind of afraid that when this is all
over that I'm gonna get left it again
I'm afraid that we're gonna go back to a
world that traditionally has left a lot
of other people behind - I never
expected that I would be so terrified to
accidentally kill someone and not even
know it every single time I leave the
house or see someone I know and give
them a hug like basic human contact and
they could be going home to someone um
it's at risk I never expected to feel so
much gratitude for complete strangers as
a recent cancer survivor it's super
important that I don't interact with
anyone that has any sicknesses or of
course köppen 19
so the people that have been taking this
seriously and staying home that means
the world to me I never expected that we
all have to choose between the lives of
two human beings
that's what's happening because our
healthcare system one of the best in the
world is literally collapsing
there are numerous pieces in the
hospital and literally we have to choose
between the life of a you know ideal her
old man and younger man so that's what's
happening it's hard to stay positive but
that's what we have to do but mainly we
have to stay home and stay safe
I never expected that going outside
after three weeks of staying at home for
self-protection would be so exciting I
hope that these days will finally be
over
we'll get through this greetings from
Azerbaijan peace I never expected to
fear for my mom's life you know she had
a collapsed lung a few years ago she has
a problem with her heart in some
capacity I just I never expected to be
quarantined in my home waiting for good
news to happen on a positive note I also
never expected to fall in love with art
again I don't know if you can call this
art but who would have thought that I
would just like droppers and Mike in my
free time you know and I hope that this
video brings some sort of comfort or joy
to people because I know that throughout
your videos make me cry every time and I
just yeah I never expected any of this
to happen I don't think any of us did I
never expected that a global pandemic
would be the push I needed to call my
crush that went really well it's hard to
like take steps forward or make plans
with another person when there's just
like so much uncertainty about what the
world is going to look like or like when
you're gonna see each other next I never
expected to be engaged last Saturday and
then within a few days I have to be
separated and we're not sure when I'll
be able to spend time together
in person again I never expected to not
have a baby shower and I'm afraid that
admitting that and making that the topic
of this video is gonna kind of expose me
to some criticism because I do think
there are a lot more dramatic things
that are happening right now
some people are obviously very sick a
lot of people including myself are out
of work but I'm actually six months
pregnant and that's something I also
never expected to be it's taken me a
really long time to get to the point
where I could even conceive which is a
whole kind of personal story in itself
but I don't know I think that once it
finally happened I gave myself
permission to have these dreams about
what it would look like when I got to
have all my friends and family over and
celebrate the fact that I get to have a
child and bring a beautiful new life
into the world
anam so that's something that I mean
it's kind of like silly because I'm
getting a little emotional about it but
I just never expected to not be able to
celebrate it that way with everybody
that I loved actually physically around
me so it's also a little bit scary I
never really expected to be having a
baby in this kind of atmosphere and
environment where I guess we just don't
really know what's going to happen next
so
but all that said I'm just so thankful
for this wonderful blessing and this
crazy experience that I get to have and
I just wanted to thank you for all the
videos that you do and here's my bump if
strangers want to see it I want to thank
everyone who submitted a video for this
episode and a special thanks to PBS for
sponsoring it like I said in the intro I
chose to partner with PBS on this
project
American portrait which is focused on
telling the stories of everyday
Americans so please go on their website
that will be linked in my description
and they also have a mobile app there
you'll find different topics and
questions that you could participate in
with everything that's happening now a
topic that is at the very top of their
website is exactly what you saw on the
episode today so if you have a story of
how you've been personally affected by
the corona virus please participate in
that topic on the website where you'll
be finishing off the sentence I never
expected dot-dot-dot like I said in the
intro this documentary is going to turn
out amazing if a lot of people
contribute so help me spread the word by
also telling your friends and families
to go on the website and make a
submission as well that's pretty much it
thank you guys for everything I hope
you're staying safe I love you all and
I'll see you next week
[Music]